I'm a big believer in people can grow
develop adapt as well so I think if it's
not something that comes naturally to
you you absolutely can learn to be more
personally accountable as a leader I've
always tried to paint in the picture for
people as to you know this is the world
that we live in you know absolutely all
this stuff goes on it's you know a tough
Market there's things that might have
been done to you that aren't your fault
but it's still your responsibility to
you know find the way through that I
think yeah that's something that I
definitely look for when I'm
interviewing people for my team and for
the business and if it's not something
that comes naturally to them then I
absolutely try and you know give them
that guidance and you know show them the
reasons why it's better to have that
mindset and you know what's the benefit
going to be to them of having that
mindset or cultivating that mindset